David Shepherd is a former FBI special
agent and former director of security at
the Venetian Las Vegas he is now CEO of
the readiness resource group which
advises companies in Vegas and around
the country on security and response
training David good morning when I spoke
to the ATF special agent in charge he
said they traced all the guns and what
we're learning is that 33 of them were
purchased in just the last year alone
what does that tell us about Steven
Pataca he was definitely planning he was
playing a lot for this type of event you
have to collect supplies you have to
collect the weapons you have to collect
the ammo you have to take him do that
while in events and that's what he did
and that's what he did but it was highly
premeditated it was definitely
premeditated he picked a location they
picked the area to look down on people
elevated position to taken have a best
observation view of what was going to
happen
we just heard DeMarco Morgan talking
about those bumps tops those essentially
add-ons that allow you to turn a
semi-automatic into a machine gun those
are relatively new or those have been
around for a while they've been around
for a little while then what they end up
doing is making a full automatic weapon
that actually will shoot bullets 700
rounds per minute 700 700 rounds or more
per minute so you will stop and when he
was wearing gloves he had gloves on he
could change his guns back and forth so
he want to burn his hands he grabs
another gun it's really all about I know
you've not only been at the FBI but
involved in hotel security you know
after 9/11 we saw security change at
airports in a very significant way how
do you see security changing at hotels
right now we're training assess exactly
what's going on it's not as much as
hotels it is open our venues the venue's
right now are more susceptible to things
they always have to take worry about
trucks has been a crashed into our
people those events now we have to worry
about high altitude this is the second
one we've had in 51 years the last one
was in Texas
Ida Texas tower when 13 people were
killed we haven't had one for 51 years
until this happened but I mean the idea
I mean I heard I was there at the press
conference
with the sheriff yesterday who who was
seemed concerned that nobody saw the
fact that he brought in ten big
suitcases that he had some of this
equipment perhaps set up in his hotel
room
how could he have put together this
Arsenal and set it all up without anyone
in the hotel noticing well he wasn't
bringing gun cases in or a regular
suitcases the guns will break down you
can fit inside a case you wouldn't know
that I have guns in my cases I could
have two or three guns inside the case
and reassemble if people went in the
room they would see the guns sentient
case take an assembler and put them down
have bipods to be able to take and shoot
you wouldn't pay it you wouldn't really
know it definitely for example David
Shepherd thank you so much for joining
us we appreciate it